فاطمه خميسي مراسلتنا التي انضمت الينا من
الجليل الاعلى فاطمه اذا هجوم بعدد كبير
من الصواريخ كيف تتعامل اسرائيل حتى الان
مع هذا الهجوم وقد اعلن عن دوي سفارات
الانذار في 94 بلده ومدينه على
الحدود نعم حاله من الاستنفار الكبير نحن
نتحدث عن رشقه صاروخيه اطلقت من جنوب
لبنان باتجاه بلدات حدوديه اسرائيليه وح
ابعد ما ادى ايضا الى تفعيل صفارات
الانذار كما ذكرت في اكثر من 90 بلده
نتحدث عن دوي صفارات الانذار من الجولان
وصولا الى الى مدينه صفد والتي تبعد اكثر
من 20 م عن الحدود اللبنانيه وبالتالي
هنالك حاله من التوتر والتصعيد جدا كبيره
تشهدها هذه الجبهه الشماليه في البدايه تم
الاعلان عن تفعيل صفارات الانذار بعد
الاشتباه بتسلل عدد من المسيرات ليتضح
لاحقا ان هذه ال الفعه والرشق الصاروخيه
كانت ايضا تشمل المسيرات والصواريخ ايضا
هنالك سقوط لعده صواريخ في جبل الجرمق
وحتى هذه اللحظه لا نعلم عن وجود اصابات
او اضرار مباشره لحقت بمواقع لربما تكون
تابعه للجيش الاسرائيلي في تلك المنطقه
ولكن نتحدث عن حدث استثنائي كبير
اي شهدته هذه الجبهه في ساعات الصباح قبل
نصف ساعه تقريبا دوي صفارات الانذار في
اكثر من ارب 90 بلده وهذا حدث استثنائي
وكبير القناه الثان ع الاسرائيليه تقول
انه لربما تم تفعيل صفارات الانذار في
اكثر من نقطه بسبب اطلاق القبه الحديديه
لعدد كبير من صواريخ الدفاعات الجويه
لاعتراض المسيرات والصواريخ ولكن حتى هذه
اللحظه لم يتم اعلان اي اصابات او اضرار
مباشره ولكن الجبهه ال الداخليه للجيش
الاسرائيلي تقول بان الحدث قد انتهى وانه
يوجد فقط
سقوط لصواريخ في مناطق مفتوحه بالقرب من
جبل الجرمق وهذه يعني اخر التعليمات نتحدث
عن حاله من الاستنفار الشديد ومن التاهب
الامني خاصه بعد عمليه اغتيال نائب رئيس
المكتب السياسي لحركه حماس صالح العاروري
كان هنالك انتشار لمنصات اضافيه للقبه
الحديديه في مناطق ابعد عن الحدود مع
لبنان ايضا كان هنالك تعليمات بفتح
الملاجئ في مدينه حيفا وحاله من الاستنفار
العسكري على طول الحدود مع لبنان الجيش
الاسرائيلي بدا بالرد عبر المدفعيه
الاسرائيليه وقام بقصف اطراف البلدات
الحدوديه ولكن لربما نكون في اطار توسيع
لرقعه المواجهه نحن نتحدث عن دوي في مناطق
ابعد وفي مناطق اكثر وهنالك ايضا نسمع
الان تحليق للطيران الاسرائيلي في الاجواء
المنطقه هنا في الجليل الاعلى طبعا
التعليمات لازالت ت على حالها اخلاء
المناطق والبلدات الحدوديه الاسرائيليه
وفتح الملاجئ في الاماكن القريبه نتحدث
ايضا عن اكثر من 40 بلده حدوديه اسرائيليه
تم اخلائها من ساكنيها اكثر من 70,000
اسرائيلي تم توزيعهم على الفنادق في اطار
هذه المواجهه وفي اطار هذا التوتر على
المستوى السياسي وعلى مستوى التصريحات
ايضا كان هنالك زياره قبل يومين للمبعوث
الامريكي عام سكشين الذي حاول التوسط
ومحاوله ايضا لمنع تدهور الاوضاع هنا على
الجبهه الشماليه من مواجهه الى حرب شامله
مع لبنان كان ايضا هناك زياره وجوله
لتقييم الاوضاع الامنيه اجراها وزير
الدفاع الاسرائيلي يوف جلنت يوم امس من
الجبهه الشماليه وقال ان اسرائيل تريد
اللجوء الى الخيار الدبلوماسي السياسي
لمنع تدهور الامور ولمنع فتح جبهه ثانيه
ولكن في حال فشل المساعي الدبلوماسيه
والوساطات الامريكيه وايضا الفرنسيه فهي
ستلج الى خيار الحرب لدفع عناصر حزب الله
بالقوه للرجوع الى خلف حدود نهر الليطاني
وبالتالي ستتمكن اسرائيل
باعاده ساكني ساكني منطقه الشمال الى
بلداتهم وهذا هو الحل الوحيد الذي تراه
ممكنا اما نجاح العمليه السياسيه
والمفاوضات بالتوصل لحل يمنع تدهور الامور
الى تصعيد والى حرب شامله او سوف تلجا الى
الخيار العسكري وتقوم بشن حرب كبيره على
حزب الله وتامين المنطقه العازله وازاله
عناصر وازاله التهديد الذي يمثله عناصر
حزب الله في المنطقه الحدوديه عبر الخيار
العسكري هذه هي صوره المشهد هنا نحن
نتحدث عن حدث استثنائي كبير ولربما يقع في
اطار الرد اي رد حزب الله المرتقب على
عمليه اغتيال صالح العاروري وكان الامين
العام لحزب بالله قد اكد ان هنالك رد وا
المستوى السياسي والعسكري في اسرائيل ياخذ
هذه التهديدات بشكل جدي وهو ما انعكس ايضا
على حاله الاستنفار هنا في الجبهه
الشماليه نتحدث ايضا بنقل الويه من قطاع
غزه الى الجبهه الشماليه تحسبا لتدهور
الامور على المستوى الامني وما حصل صباح
اليوم لربما يكون مؤشر في اننا امام ايام
سوف تشهد تصعيد وسوف تشهد رد من قبل
الفصائل المقاوم
الفلسطينيه الناشطه في جنوب لبنان وايضا
من قبل حزب الله ما حصل اليوم يختلف عن
المواجهه التقليديه التي اعتدنا عليها في
الايام السابقه منذ بدء هذه المواجهه
العسكريه في الثامن من اكتوبر نتحدث عن
رشقات صاروخيه بعيده المدى نسبيا تفعل
صفارات الانذار في اكثر من 90 نقطه وهو
حدث استثنائي وكبير ولربما يكون لديه
تداعيات ايضا على جنوب لبنان عبر الرد
الاسرائيل نحن نتحدث ايضا البارحه كان
هنالك هجمات استباقيه شنها الجيش
الاسرائيلي في مواقع مختلفه في جنوب لبنان
استهدف منطقه مجد الزون وعيت الشعب وقال
بانه استهدف مناطق عسكريه تابعه لحزب الله
نقاط مراقبه وايضا بنى تحتيه ينشط فيها
عناصر حزب الله وهذا في اطار الرد
الاستباقي ايضا البارحه كان هنالك عمليات
محدوده طالت كريات شموني برشقات صاروخيه
نتحد حث عن اكثر من 10 صواريخ اطلقت
باتجاه كريات شموني الدفاعات الجويه
اعترضت بعد هذه الصواريخ ومن ثم سلاح
الجوي الاسرائيلي والمدفعيه الاسرائيليه
قاموا بمهاجمه مواقع يقال بانها مصادر
لاطلاق هذه الصواريخ في الاراضي لبنانيه
وقالوا بانهم استهدفوا مواقع عسكريه تابعه
لحزب الله وايضا خليه تابعه لحزب الله هذا
على اخر مستوى التطورات نعم فاطمه خميسي
مراسله الجزير الان ارتفع يعني عدد
الصواريخ الى اكثر من 40 صاروخا نعم اذا
سنبقى طبعا في المتابعه معك فاطمه خمايسي
مراسله الجزيره من الجليل الاعلى شكرا لك
و